he used to bake bread and sell it in
order to earn money to buy a unicycle i
think we all could agree that that's one
of the most brooklyn things we've ever
heard but he's not from brooklyn so
everyone please welcome jonathan
all right it's uh it's awesome to be
here be here for the last slot of the
day
too bad we can't be there in person but
this is this is how these things go
so
today i want to tell you a story
about a project that we've been working
on
it's a project that involves the art
package as jared mentioned and a bit
more than the art package too
and i'm sure that you're all wondering
what kind of story is this is this going
to be any good
and all i can say is
i had a lot of fun i had a blast working
on this project so i hope that you
enjoy hearing about it
before we get started the story i need
to give a shout out to my
collaborator and colleague john harmon
he was really the brains behind this
whole operation so none of this would
have been possible without john every
step of the way
all right our story begins about a year
before the pandemic in those happy
innocent days shortly after
google had released its
burt language model
and
we were working on translating for
implementing burk in r because it had
been released in python
now this is not a story about burke but
just to give a little bit of context and
background i want to
say a few words about what burt is
you can understand bert best as a
what is a model that produces
dynamic word vectors
so
it produces representations of words
that depend on the context that that
instance of the word appeared
for example
consider these two sentences which are
both answers to the question of why
didn't the chicken cross the road
these two sentences are the same except
for the very last word the chicken
didn't cross the road because
it was too tired or because it was too
wide now that last word that changes the
context of these sentences enough that
the meanings of some of these other
words change so if it is too tired
then it is probably the chicken
but if it is too wide then it is
probably the road and you can see below
here i plotted
uh the
the word vectors for some of the words
in these sentences and when it was too
tired
you see
the the vectors for chicken and road it
all right there and when it is too wide
you see the vectors for chicken in it
and road and between these two sentences
it chicken and road don't change very
much but the vector for it changes quite
a lot
and it's closer to chicken when it's
tired and it's closer to road than it's
too wide
so as a really brief introduction to
what bert is and what it can do it's
pretty cool is these context dependent
word vectors
and so
we wanted to be able to do this sort of
thing in r
and so we were digging through the code
of the the repository that was released
in python
and
i came as i was digging through the
tokenization part of the code the tokens
were mentioned in it in the previous
talk so we'll talk about that a little
bit as i was digging through the
tokenization part of the code
i came upon
a comment in the documentation that
really got my attention
before i can show you what that comment
is
or why it was so intriguing
we need to take another brief detour and
talk about what tokenization is just to
make sure we're all on the same page
here
so briefly tokenization in natural
language processing
is
taking the input text and we're
generally dealing with text in this
context taking the input text and
turning it into a sequence of
definite pieces
which we'll call tokens
and the most obvious way to tokenize
text at least in english is to divide it
into words
for example suppose i have the text
i have clumsy figures where i
intentionally put a typo in that last in
the last word
if i break this into words
it would be i have clumsy figures
now most of the models that we're going
to be dealing with have a specific set
of recognized tokens they know about
so that's like a a token vocabulary
and if a word is found in that
vocabulary okay then
it's a token we recognize it if the word
like figures is not found then it's just
let's say unknown or something
so the the tokenization of this sentence
might be i have clumsy unknown if we
have a fixed vocabulary and generally of
course if we have a vocabulary then the
tokens
from the perspective of the model are
just represented by their index in the
vocabulary their numeric id
now you can imagine there's going to be
a bit of difficulty
if you think about language
because the number of possible words is
enormous you know there are hundreds of
thousands of english words order of a
million english words not including
typos like figneres
and
if you had a token vocabulary of
a million tokens that would just be
completely infeasible for a lot of
current language models
so you have to have you have to pick and
choose have a smaller
token vocabulary than the number of
possible words and no matter how big
your vocabulary actually is there's
always going to be some words that you
will come across whether because of
typos or new words or whatever
that are not in your vocabulary
so there's these out of vocabulary words
and we have to decide how to deal with
them we could just deal with them by
ignoring them saying i don't know what
this word is the unknown token there the
way bert
deals with out of vocabulary words is it
uses the word piece tokenization
algorithm what that basically does is
if any word that it comes across is not
found in the token vocabulary it just
breaks into pieces that are found in the
social vocabulary so it would tokenize
figurers as fig
urs
this is not a completely crazy thing to
do remember what bert does is
it's
context sensitive so when you have a
bunch of tokens that are next to each
other in the sentence
it's not unreasonable to break a word
into into pieces because
the tokens can influence each other even
if they're if they're separated like
that
so just to point out you'll see this
this hash hash here we'll be seeing a
lot of that in this talk this is just a
convention
in the word piece algorithm
that hash hash means that this
particular token is a fragment it
doesn't occur as a standalone token in
any input text it's the result of
breaking this word up into pieces
so
it it just it makes a distinct token
from
the token without it and it's just a
clue to humans that these words that
these tokens all work together
okay so i was just learning all of that
that word piece
and i was looking in the documentation
for wordpiece invert and i came across
this this comment in particular i saw
this example here
said if you if the input say this
tokenizer is the word unaffable
the output would be
and my first reaction was well that's
pretty cool look not only did it it
broke this word up you know tokenized
into these pieces but some of the pieces
are kind of meaningful here you know the
un prefixes pulled off and the able
suffix is pulled off like this is
yeah this is a pretty smart tokenizer
so
you know
i went ahead and implemented this
tokenizer in r and i i ran it with the
input unaffable
you know expecting to get this nice
breakdown unaffectable
but what i got was slightly different
from what i've been advertised
and i looked at like
those those pieces aren't particularly
meaningful at all
did i
make a mistake with a tokenizer did i
introduce a bug somewhere then i went
back looked at that documentation
you know wordpiece
is cool but it's not really a very smart
algorithm after all all it does is a
greedy
longest match first
so it looks at a word if it's not in the
token vocabulary it just starts peeling
off pieces the longest pieces it can
start at the beginning until it gets to
the end of the
of the word and so in this case una
got peeled off because it's longer than
on
okay so
wordpiece
doesn't generally break words into
meaningful pieces just kind of
you know a random process in some ways
and to illustrate what can happen with
this
i channeled my inner high schooler and
produced this abomination of a sentence
i'm not going to insult you by reading
the sentence out loud but it contains
lots of composite words lots of
different pieces lots of there's a lot
of separate morphemes in these words
where morphemes are
a unit of meaning in words
and these are rare enough words that
these are not in the token vocabulary so
a lot of these are out of vocabulary for
wordpiece
and i ran this to the word piece
tokenizer
and it turned into an even bigger
abomination
there is if you look at that breakdown
of the words here there are very few
tokens there that have any
intrinsic meaning to them that are
related to to the particular words in
question and when they are like overseas
here
there's
is a misleading
sense of meaning because it comes from
the word overseason
okay so
this planted the idea in our minds well
wouldn't it be better
if we had a tokenizer that did break
words into meaningful pieces
i mean burt's doing pretty well brook's
a pretty awesome model
but wouldn't it be even better if its
tokenizer was a bit smarter
and you know there are aesthetic reasons
for wanting it as i as i illustrated in
the previous slide it kind of feels nice
where it is broken along
meaningful lines but there are some
reasons to believe that a meaningful
tokenization would be advantageous in
training these language models
for example
if you have really uncommon words
in your your text input like consider
the word unsatisfyingness that's a
pretty uncommon word you may never have
even come across that word so far in
your life
it's it's a word but barely it occurs in
the google books corpus but hardly at
all
and yet you know exactly what that word
means because you know what all the
morphemes in that word mean
unsatisfied beingness
so in the same kind of way if a
language model
encounters a really uncommon word that
it's seen rarely or not at all in its
training
if that word
can be tokenized into
more meaningful pieces that are much
more common and for which we do have
good representations of the meaning
then we have a much better chance that
our model does something reasonable with
that combination of morphemes because it
knows the meaning of each piece or has
representation of the meaning of each
piece and so the combination will
retain some of that meaning
so this isn't particularly important
when you're working in more specialized
domains like scientific or technical
domains where you do encounter a lot of
uncommon words
and
they're
meaningful pieces in those words
even for common words
there is some potential benefit to
breaking
those words apart into pieces along
morphemic lines or peeling off suffixes
prefixes and inflections
so within the morpheme piece token
vocabulary there's about a dozen
different tokens that relate to some
variation on the word open
if open opens opened opening each of
these is in the token vocabulary as its
own token
similarly for words like close or almost
anywhere you can think of there's lots
of small variations on that work what
this means is that the
a lot of the tokens in the word piece
token vocabulary are used up
for the same word we have to have lots
of tokens for the same basic concept and
the model has to learn that concept
for these tokens
or separately
we could save a lot of tokens
if we could break apart these words
along meaningful lines so if we could
peel off inflections or prefixes as i
was saying then we could cover the same
set of words with much fewer tokens
this would leave us more space in our
limited vocabulary for a greater variety
of base words like we could have more
unique words in our vocabulary if we
didn't have to use so many tokens just
covering variations on these common
words too
so you know there are
a couple different reasons that we might
like to
to have a morpheme based tokenizer and i
just want to say we're not the only ones
that have been thinking along these
lines there's been a number of papers
over the years that are looking at
tokenization specifically with bert or
wordpiece and
considering how it could be better if it
did morpheme based
breakup
so we had this idea a while back and
every now and then
over the last year and a half
we'd say
oh yeah remember that thing
we should do it
that would be really useful
but
we
you know why didn't we do it
or sooner why don't we do it sooner
because even though it's kind of the
idea behind this tokenization is rather
simple
know it turns out be kind of tricky to
actually do this
how are we gonna break apart rule break
apart words along meaningful lines
are we gonna write an algorithm that has
a lot of rules for just breaking apart
words like that sounds really hard
there's lots of special cases there's
lots of exceptions and different
spellings like and even then you've only
covered english right
or whatever language you're working in
so that seems like
you know a very impractical approach
the only other approach we can think of
is that there's
basically a lookup table if i want to
tokenize a word along
into its morphemes
i should have a big table that i look up
that word in
and i find the breakdown and
return that
now that's also hard because
there are lots of words if you think
again about how many different
variations there are open or closed like
there are hundreds of thousands of words
in the english language and
we don't have time to write
that
to make that lookup table ourselves
yeah so we you know we sat on this idea
for quite a while because
yeah it is tricky you know
it's it's not obvious
how we can do this with the limited time
that we have
so
thinking about this a bit more what we
really want to find
is
a group of people who care about words
enough
that they are going to willingly spend
their own free time
entering
morphological information about words
into publicly available
databases
and yes yes
i see a wictionary wiktionary turns out
to be almost exactly what we need
so look at this if i look up the word
unsurprisingly in wiktionary look right
there in the etymology section it tells
me that's
that's formed from unsurprising plus the
suffix li
and i keep going unsurprising is
unsurprising and surprising i put all
these together and i find that i have
the breakdown for unsurprisingly right
here
if i if i use the hash hash notation
just to make it look more like wordpiece
i get something like this
all right so this is exactly what we're
looking for right we want to find out
how words break down along these
morphemic lines
now it's not every case in dictionary is
as
easy as this example makes it look but
for the most part wiktionary has the
data we're looking for it's not complete
there's a lot of gaps in it still it's
always it's going to be continuing work
in progress
but
wiktionary is a treasure trove of
morphemic data here
and you know honestly the
once we have that the rest of the
the story almost writes itself
what we do is we we break words apart by
recursively looking them up in
wiktionary so look up the word look at
its pieces and keep doing that until we
don't get any more break parts
so we
you know we hit the wait the api over
and over or actually uh process a dump
file so we don't have to hit the api so
many times
we do that for every
word
and wictionary now we're working in
english just to kind of you know i i
heard that last thought yes we're
working in english because that's the
language that we speak
but what's nice about this process is
reactionary has a lot of
what other language information too so
the process that we are piloting here
could in principle be used in other
languages if that were relevant and
other languages there's some other
languages that are much heavier
uh more morphemic than english yes so
this could be even more crucial for
those languages
so once we have the lookup table once
you've generated that lookup table for
all the english words in dictionary we
also have all the tokens that came out
of that process and we can select
an optimal set of those to include in
our token vocabulary now wordpiece has
token vocabulary is around 30 000 that's
the size of the vocabulary so let's just
take about 30 000 tokens
and
the best most common tokens and use
those as our token vocabulary
and then we'll keep the subset of the
lookup that is covered by that
vocabulary
so which words
get processed into our token vocabulary
now in practice we find that if i have a
30 000 token vocabulary
that will cover
over 300 000 words which is
comparable to the number of words and
the largest print dictionaries that you
can get so that's that's nothing this
means that it's a pretty sizable list of
words right there that we have
and look up for now
for for a relatively modest size token
vocabulary
and then there's always going to be some
words that are not in the vocabulary not
in the lookup table so we still have to
process those somehow so we'll just let
those words fall back on the wordpiece
algorithm
actually we'll modify the wordpress
algorithm a little bit so it can also
include prefixes
like we have now and instead of just
doing the greedy first algorithm from
the beginning we'll also do it from the
end of the word go both ways and pick
the the best breakdown so we modified
the word face algorithm slightly as our
fallback but it's it's basically
wordpiece
once you put all these pieces together
we can rewrite the function and there we
have it we can tokenize text using our
morpheme piece tokenizer
so it takes some text in and you break
it up long morphing lines
let's look at a few detail a few
examples of this so you can kind of see
how it works i took a couple of
sentences from
technical articles or journals
so tokenization is the process of
demarcating and possibly classifying
sections of a string of characters
i tokenized that using word piece and
morphine piece and you can see the
differences there there's there's a few
words they tokenize differently i want
to highlight in particular the word
demarcating wordpiece doesn't know what
to do with that word it's not in the
vocabulary so it just breaks it up
into relatively meaningless pieces dem
are caving
whereas morphine piece it finds that
word in its lookup table and so it
tokenizes it as demarcate
now that's kind of one of the key words
in this sentence
and wordpiece
obscures it completely morphine piece
by being sensitive to this
preserves the meaning of that word
or at least breaks into tokens that
likely have have meaning
here's another example a morpheme is the
smallest meaningful lexical item in a
language
word piece
the morphing piece again there's a few
differences between them but because
morpheme piece has a more efficient
token vocabulary for reasons that i
mentioned it has room in its
its token vocabulary for the word
morpheme because wordpress doesn't and
so in wordpiece morpheme gets broken up
to three pieces morph in
right whereas
morpheme is a as a complete token and
morpheme piece
one more example just because one of the
things i really enjoyed about this
project was finding
obscure unusual words
i learned so much about so many things
doing this
uh the word quasi-hemi demi semi quaver
is actually a real word my kids really
enjoy
saying this word now
and morphine piece
it breaks it up in those meaningful
pieces quasi emmy demi semi flavor
i'll let you guys guess at what this
word means if you don't already know
just to close the loop here that
abomination the sentence that i
constructed earlier is still an
abomination but at least with morphine
piece just
the bottom there
it's at least a meaningful abomination
and you can see how
the
the morphine piece breaks it into
meaningful tokens you can at least parse
with that what each word means there
and
say so what's next what are the next
steps in this project for us
uh as jared just mentioned um we
actually got the morphin piece package
accepted to crane just this morning so
that step is already done we have the
package on crayon but this is really
more than an r package you want this
tokenization algorithm to be accessible
to
everybody no matter what language you
use so one of our next steps is to get
this algorithm implemented in python as
well so that
it can be used because what we really
want to do we really should do is test
our hypothesis which we really haven't
done yet we want to see if this
tokenization makes a difference
for
training language models it makes a
difference in performance on downstream
tasks so one of our big next steps is to
actually test this pre-train a model
like a bert like model using a morphing
piece tokenization and compare that to
the results using a wordpiece
tokenization and see if there's any
tasks that this is this better on
if anyone is interested in collaborating
we are open to partnerships for this
particular project because
the resources for this will start to get
significant
that that is the story that i have for
you uh
as i said i had a whole lot of fun
working on this and it's not over yet
and i hope you enjoy hearing about it
thanks
thank you very much
uh morpheme piece sounds like it's
actually gonna be a big leap forward
that sounds really amazing um
and you know you want to pour this
multiple languages it sounds like
something west mckinney has talked about
a lot so
i hope you're writing this in like
something like c plus and you just put a
r or python wrapper around this
or
head that way